En este video veremos cómo se relacionan las
áreas de regiones de triángulos utilizando
tres teoremas. Estas relaciones serán muy útiles
en tu vida cotidiana, así que empecemos. Imagina
que tenemos un triángulo y trazamos una ceviana.
Una ceviana es simplemente una recta que une el
vértice de un triángulo con un punto en el lado
opuesto. Observa que en este caso se forman dos
nuevas regiones internas triangulares: el área de
la región interna A y el área de la región interna
B; además, el lado opuesto al vértice se divide en
dos partes: tenemos una longitud m y una longitud
n. Siempre que hagamos una división similar, sin
importar la ceviana que tomemos, puede ser esta o
esta, o esta, se va a crear la siguiente relación
entre las áreas y las partes del lado opuesto:
el área de la región interna A entre la longitud
del lado m es igual al área de la región interna
B entre la longitud del lado n (A/m = B/n). Por
ejemplo, si sabemos que el área de la región
interna A mide 20 m² y las dos partes en las que
se divide el lado opuesto son m de 4 m y n de 8 m,
entonces ¿cuál es el área de la región B? Bueno,
si sustituimos en la relación, tenemos que el área
de la región interna A, que son 20 m², entre la
longitud del lado m, que son 4 m, es igual al área
de la región interna B, entre la longitud del lado
n, que son 8 m, o, dicho de otra manera, el área
de la región interna B = 8m • 20m²/4m. 2 metros
se cancelan y nos quedan 8 por 20, lo cual es 160,
entre 4, que es 40 m². Un dato interesante es que
si la ceviana corta al lado opuesto en el punto
medio se llamará mediana. Las medianas serán muy
útiles entre trigonometría en varias ocasiones,
y cuando tenemos una mediana se cumple que el
área de la región interna A es igual al área de
la región interna B. Bien, con esto en mente,
veamos otro ejemplo un poco más interesante de
este mismo teorema. Esta vez nos piden encontrar
el área total de la región triangular. ¿Cómo
podemos hallarla usando el teorema 1? Pausa el
video e inténtalo. Observa que el lado AB está
dividido por la recta OP en dos longitudes: una
que mide b y otra 3b. Además, nos dicen que el
área de una región interna es de 2. ¿Qué tal
si trazamos el triángulo ABP? Bueno, observa
este triángulo interno: el lado AB está dividido
por la ceviana OP y lo corta en dos longitudes,
b y 3b. Si a la región AOP la llamamos x y si
la región BOP mide 2, siguiendo el teorema 1,
entonces se debe cumplir que: 2/b = x/3b, o dicho
de otra manera: x debe de ser igual a 3b • 2 / b,
lo cual es igual a 6. Esta primera región que
buscábamos mide 6. Muy bien, pero no hemos
acabado aún. Ya sabemos que el área de esta región
interna BOP mide 2 y la región interna AOP mide 6,
entonces el área de la región interna APB mide 8.
Ahora tenemos que encontrar el área de la región
interna APC para conocer el área total. ¿Cómo
la encontramos? Bueno, utilicemos de nuevo el
teorema 1. Ya que, observa, el lado BC del
triángulo ABC se corta por la mediana AP en
dos longitudes iguales. Estos puntos representan
distancias iguales, siempre que los veamos querrá
decir que tenemos dos longitudes iguales, por lo
tanto, el área de estas dos regiones internas debe
de medir lo mismo. Esto utilizando el teorema 1,
es decir, esta otra región también mide 8. Por
lo tanto, el área total de la región triangular
completa ABC es de 8 + 8, que es 16, y ya está,
con esto acabamos este ejemplo. Pasa algo similar
si tenemos dos triángulos que tienen un ángulo en
común. Este es el segundo teorema: la relación
entre las áreas y los lados que forman el ángulo
en común está dada por el área del triángulo
grande, es decir, el área A entre el área del
triángulo pequeño, es decir, el área B, es igual a
la longitud del lado a por la longitud del lado b,
entre la longitud del lado m, por la longitud del
lado n (A/B = a•b/m•n). Por ejemplo, si queremos
encontrar el valor del área de la región A y
sabemos que el lado a mide 25 mm, el lado b mide
27 mm, que el área de la región B es de 10 mm²,
que el lado m mide 15 mm y el lado n mide 12 mm,
entonces tenemos que, en esta expresión, al
sustituir los datos obtendremos que el área
de la región A, entre el área de la región B, que
vale 10 mm², es igual a la longitud del lado a,
que es 25 mm, por la longitud del lado b, que es
de 27 mm, entre la longitud del lado m, que son
15 mm, por la longitud del lado n, que son 12 mm,
y esto es igual a, si sacamos nuestra calculadora
nos va a quedar que: 25 x 27, todo esto dividido
entre 15 x 12, es igual a 3.75. Entonces el área
de la región A va a ser igual a 3.75 x 10 mm²,
que es lo mismo que: 37.5 mm². Por último,
es importante mencionar que también podemos
relacionar el área de triángulos semejantes,
así que no te distraigas, este teorema 3 también
es muy útil. Si sabemos que dos triángulos son
semejantes, es decir, tienen la misma forma pero
no tienen el mismo tamaño, o dicho de otra manera,
si sus tres ángulos son iguales, entonces la
siguiente expresión nos da la relación entre las
áreas de dos triángulos semejantes: el área del
triángulo grande A, entre el área del triángulo
pequeño B es igual a la longitud del lado a²,
entre la longitud del lado m², que es igual a
la longitud de lado b², entre la longitud del
lado n², que es igual a la longitud del lado c²
entre la longitud de lado n². Bien, veamos un caso
particular. Si sabemos que el área de la región B,
es decir del triángulo pequeño, mide 100 km² y
que el lado a mide 25 km y el lado m mide 5 km,
¿cuál es el valor del área de la región A, es
decir, el valor del área del triángulo grande?
Bueno, apliquemos la relación entre las áreas
de triángulos semejantes. Tenemos que el área
del triángulo grande, es decir, el área de la
región A entre el área del triángulo pequeño,
que son 100 km², es igual a 25 km, esto elevado al
cuadrado entre 5 km, esto elevado al cuadrado, lo
cual es lo mismo que, bueno: 25 x 25 es 625, 625
km² / 5 x 5 es 25, 25 km², y 625 / 25, esos 25,
y los kilómetros cuadrados se cancelan. Entonces,
el área de la región A, es decir el área del
triángulo grande, es igual a 25 x 100 km², lo cual
es 2500 km², y ya está. En este video aprendimos
que se pueden relacionar las áreas internas de
un triángulo usando una ceviana, también vimos
cómo se relacionan las áreas de triángulos con un
ángulo en común y cómo se relacionan las áreas de
triángulos semejantes. Eso va a ser todo por
este video, así que nos vemos en el siguiente.